Elizabeth Renzetti of globe and mail com
wrote an article recently about a keep
up I don't know if the two of you happen
to read it but she basically said if
Iggy Pop can't live off of his art than
what chance do we all have and I'm just
going to play the part of Elizabeth for
a second so she writes a new reality has
tripped him up and it's the same one
shafting artists all over the world
namely that everyone wants to listen and
no one wants to pay so in short the cat
is out of the bag and the new electronic
devices which estranged people from
their morals also make it easier to
steal music ie content then pay for it
we know this is something that the two
of you have had to deal with we wanted
to get your thoughts on it I'm gonna
start you did start with a hard question
okay go ahead start so yeah my feeling
is that were in a period of transition
more than anything I don't necessarily
think that what is going on right now is
the future I think things are always
changing and yeah I agree that right now
it's it's particularly difficult to
monetize your art especially if you're
doing something if you're trying to do
something very independent and very
outside of the system but I don't
necessarily think this you know that
people I I guess I feel like a monetized
solution is coming and I think we're
slowly going to enter into a period
where you know artists really find their
niche and figure out how to survive I
don't necessarily I think right now a
lot of people are still thinking about
the heyday of you know the last 20 years
you know where DVDs and ancillary
markets were like a big thing and
everybody's still the industry as a
whole is still kind of clinging to the
money that they were making on that
market but I don't necessarily think and
I think it just hurts particularly hard
right now same thing with the music
industry it hurts right now because
we're just going through this transition
but I guess optimistically I think it's
going to kind of work its work its way
out yeah I think it's two things I think
its ease of access and the whole piracy
the idea or movement has happened out of
a reaction to ease of access and things
being really overpriced I think that
when you know when I was a teenager I
spent all my babysitting money on CDs
that cost fifteen eighteen dollars and I
might only like one song on the album
but then you've just shelled out
eighteen dollars and so I think it's a
same with the cost of DVDs and blu-rays
and and people just keep trying really
hard to keep locking up territories and
making region coded discs and
ultraviolet this and you know this
digital rights management and the longer
that Hollywood and the record industry's
keep trying to push people out and
charge them a lot the angrier they get
and there's got to be a happy medium at
some point and hopefully there will be
whether it's a bittorrent bundle or that
with a pay gate or just something that's
eliminates the barrier of access and
also eliminates the overpriced nature of
how things are so that's that's my hope
is what's happening
you